it's a decision day for oklahoma
quarterback kyler murray the 2018
heisman trophy winner has to make a
threshold decision on whether to apply
for early admission to the nfl draft if
he doesn't then he's not getting in this
year he has one year of eligibility left
in oklahoma and presumably if he
wouldn't enter the draft he would be
picking baseball over football but he
can still delay the final decision
there's nothing that keeps him from
entering the nfl draft nothing that
keeps him from being drafted ultimately
the question is would he sign an nfl
contract and i think the oakland a's who
hold his rights and who have given him a
4.66 million dollar signing bonus i
think they are playing this in a way
that maybe keeps the door as open as
possible for murray to play baseball
knowing that there's a possibility that
at some point if he's not drafted high
enough he chooses baseball over football
and the fact that he hasn't slammed the
door on baseball could make it harder
for him to be drafted as high as
possible by an nfl team that's the one
thing i was told after he won the
heisman trophy and we started poking
around into what his nfl prospects were
he needs to make it clear that football
is his sport in order to be drafted as
high as possible because no one wants to
waste a first-round pick on a guy who
isn't going to play football it happened
to the tampa bay buccaneers back in 1986
when they made bo jackson the first
overall selection what did he do he
played baseball instead so that's the
challenge for murray if he wants to be
drafted as high as he can be in football
he needs to at some point slam the door
on baseball for now he doesn't need to
slam that door today we find out whether
or not the door is open for his entry
into the nfl draft
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports